مشاهدينا نذهب الى هذه الصور التي وصلتنا
للتوم من مخيم شعفاط اللاجئين الفلسطينيين
على حدود القدس وهذه المواجهات بين
الفلسطينيين
والاسرائيليين في المخيم مخيم شعفاط الى
المشاهدين كانت الشرطه الاسرائيليه قد
اعلنت ان خير علقم منفذ عمليه
مستوطنه النبي يعقوب في القدس بالامس هو
من سكان المخيم من سكان مخيم شعفاط
اللاجئين الفلسطينيين همم في على تخوم
القدس همم كان بالامس قد شهد كذلك حركه
مواجهات كذلك واضطرابات ما بين
الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين بعد الاعلان
على ان منفذ عمليه النبي يعقوب هو من مخيم
شعفاط طبعا العمليه التي ادت الى مقتل همم
ثمانيه همم اسرائيليين
يعني التوتر مازال موجوده ااا نشاهد هنا
يعني استخدام للالعاب الناريه لا نعلم اذا
كان هذا ضمن
محاوله للتشويش على القوات
الاسرائيليه او على الاسرائيليين على
العموم كان بالامس كان هناك بعض
الاشتباكات في المخيم طبعا
بعد الاعلان على ان خير علقم منفذ عمليه
النبي يعقوب هو من مخيم شعفاط هذه الصور
اذن من المخيم قبل قليل